[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW REINHART:
Hey, everybody.
Hi.
Thanks for having me.
Did you guys have a good lunch?
Yeah, me too.
I'm telling you, I
want to work here.
Because that lunch was awesome.
I don't make anything near that.
Anyways, my name is
Matthew Reinhart.
And I make pop-up books.
Some people call me
a paper engineer.
Some people call me a
children's book Illustrator.
I like to think of myself as
all those things and many more.
And today, I'm going to show
you a little bit about how
I do what I do.
I'm also going to make a
pop-up book here and show
you some things that you can
actually make at home, too.
So let's get started.
Say hello-- see, I always
have to put notes for myself
in these presentations.
It helps me a lot
when I'm doing it
to say hello and get started.
So we got that done.
All right, very good.
All right, so when
I was young, I
had no idea that
there was such a thing
as a paper engineer or a
pop-up book maker or whatever.
I was just a kid.
I liked to ride bikes.
My fashion sense
was a little off.
But I didn't know.
And you guys are really lucky.
Everyone's really lucky to
be able to come here and be
with your parents and
see what they do at work.
It's really important.
As you get older, you get to
learn about what things work
and what things work for
you and what things you
might like to do as a
job and other things
you may not like to do.
So growing up, my parents
did different things.
And I would go to work with.
Here is-- my mother was
an aerobic instructor.
There I am in the background,
if you can see, really.
And yes, it was the '80s.
It's not my fault.
My dad was a dentist.
Here I am at the
dentist, helping my dad.
He only let me use that
drill once, though.
Yeah.
But anyways, I look
good in scrubs.
But seriously though, tell
a little about myself--
so enough of the jokes.
So I have always sort of--
growing up, my dad
was in the Navy.
We lived all over the place.
The one thing that I always
took with me was artwork.
So I always drew.
I always made stuff.
There I am in that corner
there when I was really young,
writing my first book.
It was a novel.
It took me forever.
But I was always making things.
I was always drawing.
And I was creating
things with my hands.
Because that was what
could come with me.
If I didn't have friends in a
new space or if we had moved,
my artwork always came with me.
So I spent a lot of time
by myself making things.
And when I was young, there
were no Michaels stores.
So getting supplies to make the
stuff wasn't always as easy.
So I was always rummaging
through the garbage or anything
extra-- making things out
of boxes, cereal boxes.
Styrofoam from any sort of
electronic that we ever got,
I was always buying
or grabbing the boxes
and making stuff out of it.
If there was a toy
that didn't exist,
I would make it myself
out of whatever I could.
Right there, you see a picture
of me with my little sister.
I think I made a little
cardboard puppetry stage.
And as usual, my
sister would destroy it
within a few seconds.
She would come over,
oh, this is great--
rip.
So that was kind of
what it was like.
This is a drawing I did, I
think back in first grade.
And I have always had an
interest in biology and zoology
and paleontology.
I love dinosaurs.
I love-- but I really
just loved making
artwork and kind of telling
stories with pictures.
As you can see also, I was a
little bit of an egomaniac.
My name is really
big up in the corner.
And I think that's kind of
translated into myself now.
But so it was--
but being an artist really
wasn't a viable option,
at least when I was
younger, for a career.
At the time, we didn't
have the Google.
And we couldn't go
online and figure out--
do our research so easily.
We had to go to those things
called libraries and things.
And we would go.
And I didn't know as much about
all the creative jobs that
are out there, all
the ways that you
can channel that creative
energy and that talent.
And so when I went
off from high school,
I didn't have a
lot of motivation
to find out what I could do.
My parents didn't want me
to be a starving artist.
They used that a
lot, all the time.
We don't want you to
be a starving artist.
And so I went to school
for my college years.
And I studied biology.
Actually, my undergraduate
degree in biological sciences.
And I was going to be a doctor.
I studied pre-med.
I went to Clemson University
for my undergraduate degree.
And you can see me.
I think I'm up in the
corner there somewhere.
Anyway, so I went to Clemson.
The entire time I
was there, though,
while I was studying
all these biology
and chemistry and
biochemistry, which
is horrible, if you've ever--
biochemistry is the worst.
After-- when I was studying
all these different things,
I felt something like--
I felt like it
wasn't quite right.
I mean, I was interested in it.
And I was pretty good at it.
And actually, I got
into medical school.
But I just-- it wasn't right.
So the whole time I was
doing all this science,
I was also doing
artwork on the side.
I was always doing sketches.
I was always making these giant
paintings of weird things.
And I wanted to see if there
was a way I could apply that
and some of my
science skill to a job
that I just didn't
know at the time.
So before I went to med
school-- like I said, I got in--
before I went to school to be
a doctor, which is a long haul.
There's a lot that goes into it.
My parents were
really pushing for it.
I told them, listen, I need a--
I want a year off
before I go to school.
And I want to live
in New York City.
And oh-- that one
went before this one.
Let's see.
So I lived in New York City.
That's the apartment that
we lived in down in--
on Canal Street, actually.
We had rats like this big.
I swear to God.
It was a really cool
space that we lived in.
But actually, we lived
over a stereo store.
So from noon till
about 7:00 at night,
the vibrations from
the stereos downstairs
would move our furniture so
that everything would shake.
And during that time when
I lived in New York City,
I worked for an
organization that
helped find corneas
for people who
had trouble with their eyes.
And I worked with
a lot of hospitals.
So I was getting an
idea of what it was
like to work with sick people.
And I realized I didn't like
working with sick people.
I didn't know if it was a good
idea for me to work as a doctor
if I didn't like doing that.
It was really hard.
And it was really scary.
And so while I was here, I
came to that realization.
And I also--
New York is a really
exciting, creative place.
I mean, there's
all kinds of people
doing all kinds of
weird jobs, things
that you would
never know existed.
And while I was in New York
at that time-- and this
was about 25 years ago, back
when the Times Square was not
filled with lots of
Disneyland-like lights
and everything.
It was a lot different.
I'm not going to go into that.
But I also was meeting
a lot of people
who were doing a lot of
different kinds of jobs
and a lot of different
kind of creative jobs.
And so I ended up going to my
parents and saying, listen,
this is not something
I want to do.
I don't want to be a doctor.
I really want to do
something creative.
And shockingly,
they told me, OK.
You can do that.
But you have to find something
where you'll be able to live.
Because we ain't
paying for you forever.
And so I did my research.
And I discovered that
there is something
called industrial design.
And that is the
design of products,
all kinds of products, whether
they be tables or scissors
or cool Nike shoes or
even toys that you get,
like action figures.
I'm a big action figure
collector, actually.
I have a huge Star
Wars figure collection,
like 2,000 different
Star Wars figures.
And I've been
collecting since '78.
So I have a lot.
And I also collect Transformers.
And you'll see a little
bit of that trickle
into the work I do.
I have a huge
Transformer collection.
Now here in New York City,
we don't have a lot of space.
So I can't have like
a Transformers room
in my apartment.
I have a Transformer closet.
But thank goodness
for off-site storage,
because that's where the
rest of my collection goes.
Anyways, I studied industrial
design at-- let's see if that
picture comes up--
Pratt Institute,
which is in Brooklyn.
And I took a grad--
I did the graduate program at
Pratt Institute, studied there
for a couple of years.
And while I was there, I--
let's see if that
other picture comes up.
There it is.
It's New York.
Well, I already told
you I was in New York.
While I was there, I worked
with a gentleman who--
he needed some help
making pop-ups.
And I was his intern.
And I just needed like an
extra job to make some money.
You know, it was OK.
I could cut up and
fold paper, whatever.
It wasn't a big deal.
I didn't really even
think about pop-ups.
In fact, growing up, I
only had one pop-up book.
And this was it.
This-- it's
dinosaurs, obviously.
And it was beautiful
illustration.
And when you opened it
up, there was a pop-up.
And it's a little different
than from some of the ones
that I do.
I do kind of a little bit
more elaborate ones like this.
But we'll-- get in there.
But I really loved it.
Now, this pop-up
ended up-- after it
was in my household for a little
while, probably about an hour
or so, it looked like
this because of one person
in the house.
So I really didn't
think about pop-ups.
It was never in my mind
or anything like that.
[LAUGHTER]
That's really-- yeah, yeah.
So pop-ups weren't in my mind.
But I would help--
when I was younger and
when I was in grad school,
I was helping this
paper engineer.
And I would cut and fold paper
and follow his instructions.
And it was a long time.
I worked for him a couple
of years, just doing this.
And when I got out of school,
I realized that maybe this
is something I can do.
And so there was a lot--
so for quite a few
years, I apprenticed.
And what that really
means is I worked.
And I would help
him with his work.
And it wasn't always the
stuff I wanted to do.
In fact, the designs,
I didn't always
like, even though he did really
beautiful work like this.
I worked with Robert
Sabuda for many years.
And he does a lot of very white,
beautiful, structural, pop-ups,
and stuff.
We worked on things for the
MOMA and other publishers.
I learned a lot from just
learning how structurally,
how this stuff--
but it wasn't always the stuff
that I wanted to do myself.
But that's really important.
In the beginning when
you're learning something,
sometimes you've
got to do the work.
And it isn't always exactly
what you want to do.
But it helps you learn.
So after years of learning
all these different principles
and learning all this
stuff how to make pop-ups,
I got to start
doing my own books.
Some of the-- the first books
I did weren't like these--
they were these
really weird books,
"The Pop-Up Book of
Phobias" and "The Pop-Up
Book of Nightmares."
They were these bizarre books.
I never even thought
they'd actually come out.
But actually, the phobia book
was really popular, especially
with therapists in the city.
Then I was able to start
making books that I really,
really was excited about.
I had-- my first "New
York Times" bestseller
was a pop-up book
of butterflies.
And after that, we were
able to create a series
about prehistoric animals.
Because I love paleontology.
First was this
dinosaur book called
"Encyclopedia Prehistorica."
And this has been translated now
to about 25 different languages
around the world.
And doing this project, it says
I collaborate-- on these books,
I collaborated
with Robert Sabuda.
He would just sort
of oversee things.
But I would do the writing, the
artwork, and the engineering,
so all parts of
making a pop-up book.
We made three in this series.
And when you make--
when you're just
starting out and you're
making these big books,
you will learn a lot.
Boy, you learn a lot.
But you make a lot of mistakes.
And each book, I look at it
and I see a lot of mistakes.
In fact, I can't
always enjoy my books
when they're finished,
because all I do is go,
oh, you could have
done that better.
Oh, that wasn't that good.
But a lot of other
people don't know that.
So I-- yes, I go to a therapist
about this sort of stuff.
So I did this series.
And then let's see
what else we got.
I've done a lot of books about
classic stories and fairytales
like "Cinderella"
and "The Jungle
Book," which is really awesome.
I love that one.
I did a series about mythology.
So I love learning about things
like mythology and history
and science.
And I like-- I kind of have
one of those minds where
I'm obsessive-- surprise.
I get obsessive about a subject.
So when I want to
learn something,
I just don't want
to learn a little.
I got to learn a lot.
And what happens,
though, when you
do that, especially when you're
creating books like this,
you have only so much space
in this biological computer
in your head.
And so when I learn
something else,
it kind of pushes
the old stuff out.
And the new stuff goes in.
So I learn stuff.
And then it pushes old stuff.
So thank God I still know
how to walk and talk.
Because I've learned so much
about all these different
subjects.
So this is mythology,
this series.
The "Gods and Heroes" book
is actually pretty cool.
It was a lot of fun to do.
I did
A book with Maurice
Sendak at one point.
Maurice Sendak did "Where
the Wild Things Are."
This pop a book
was called "Mommy?"
And it was about-- it
barely had any words in it.
But it was about a baby who
went into a mad scientist's lab.
And of course, in
Maurice's world,
the baby defeats all the
monsters in funny ways
like pulling down their pants
and doing fun stuff like that,
which of course--
I mean, it makes total sense.
I also, like I said,
really love Star Wars.
Now, I'm an old-school
Star Wars fan.
And so I did the first book
for the 30th anniversary
of the original
Star Wars trilogy.
And that's awesome.
This year is the
40th anniversary.
So that book is 10 years old.
It was incredible.
It was a huge dream come true.
It was a dream.
And it was a nightmare.
Making it, I'm so
obsessive that I had
to get everything just right.
That-- I actually put myself
in that book as a character.
So it was fun to be
able to do that and put
some of my friends.
In fact, a lot of
times in my books,
I do put family and friends,
even pets that I used to have.
In fact, in my
"Cinderella" book,
my pet rabbits from
when I was a kid
are following Cinderella
throughout the book.
Because everyone wants to
learn about Lucy, Bernadine,
and Fuzzball, my pet rabbits
from when I was young.
I also did a second
Star Wars book.
And I'll probably do
a third Star Wars book
once we're finished
with the new trilogy.
And I can't wait.
I love comic books, and
especially DC Comics.
I did two superhero
books so far.
But there may be
another big Marvel
one coming in the future.
I actually got to work with
six different comic book
artists for this book.
It was awesome to be
able to create it.
And it actually as a light-up--
some of my books have
light-up parts in them.
What they call my type of
work, paper engineering,
they call it
low-tech engineering.
Because I'm only working with
one type of material, paper.
But sometimes I use other
things like electronics.
So in this book and
in the Star Wars book,
there are electronics.
As a matter of fact, at the
end of the Star Wars book,
there's Darth Vader.
Now-- and at the top, there
are two working lights.
And now you can't tell
with the lights in here,
but that lightsaber
that Luke has lights up.
And then on the opposite side,
the Darth Vader one does.
So there's actually wires that
go in underneath the page.
I wish the lights
weren't so bright.
But you would be able
to see that better.
But anyway, it's been cool
to be able to create things
like that.
And in this one, it has a
bat signal that lights up.
It's super cool.
Yes, I'm a brony.
I totally made a Pony book.
It was awesome.
And I can't wait
for the big movie.
What's cool about working with
My Little Pony is in this book,
I actually got to
make myself a pony.
My pony name is
Professor Paper Scraps.
And I dare you to
find me in this book.
I'm somewhere in one
of the backgrounds.
So it was really cool.
I love the-- my sister loved My
Little Pony when we were young.
But the new pony
show is awesome.
And I was forced to
watch all of them.
And it was great.
It was great.
I love it.
It was-- it's really fun.
I did-- sometimes
I try to do books
where they aren't just a book.
They're something else.
This book was for the
"Game of Thrones."
And it not only becomes--
it's not only a pop-up book
about all the different places
in the "Game of Thrones"
in Westeros and everything,
it also becomes a giant map.
It's about as big as a table.
So you can enjoy it both ways.
Some people say it's important
to think outside the box.
I like to say it's important
to think outside the book.
And so there are a
lot more projects
that are coming up
that we're trying
to stretch the boundaries
of what a pop-up book can
be or just what a book can be
and how it can be interactive.
I also like to express
my feminine side.
And I am big into princesses.
So-- and I'm cool with that.
I'm cool with that, all right?
So I've done two
Disney princess books.
One was, of course, "Frozen."
Because let me tell you.
When Disney calls you
up and they say, would
you like to do a Fro--
you don't even let
them finish the word.
You say, yes.
Yes I will.
I worked on the "Frozen" book.
And let me tell you, I didn't
stop singing that song.
I would hear it in
my sleep at night.
"Let it go."
I would hear it all the time.
But it was great.
It was really fun to work on.
And I also worked on a
Disney princess book,
because I love
classic animation.
And so many of those
Disney princess movies,
especially things like
"Cinderella" and--
well, my personal favorite
is "Little Mermaid."
Those movies really transformed
the artist that I am today.
So they were really
big influences.
And so to be able
to work on that
and to make like Cinderella
super cool, that Cinderella
actually, she transforms.
So she's like, oh, I'm
all sad Cinderella.
And then you pull the
bottom of her skirt thing.
You don't pull her
skirt, but there's
a little tab on the bottom.
And it transforms into
like super fab Cinderella.
So it was really cool.
That was a hard pop to design.
Oh.
Oh, well, of course, in one
of my most recent books,
something I know that everyone
here at Google loves, LEGO.
So a couple of years ago,
the LEGO folks came to me.
And they said would, you
want to do a LEGO book.
And I didn't even let them
finish that sentence, either.
Yes, totally-- I grew
up building with LEGO.
But back when I was young, we
didn't have all the cool sets
that you guys have now.
We just had
whatever-- six colors.
And I think we
had wheels, maybe.
But it was-- we never-- when
you would make something,
it never looked like one object.
It always just kind
of look a bunch
of different bricks stuck
together, whereas now, you
have so many different pieces.
It's-- I actually, when I
was researching this book,
I tried to get the LEGO people
to tell me a number of all
the different pieces that
they've ever made-- not color,
but the types of pieces.
And they couldn't
even give it to me.
There's so many
different pieces.
They don't even have
a number for that.
So when I worked on
this book, I actually
went to the LEGO headquarters
in Billund, in Denmark.
I went to their special
design headquarters,
which is this big,
white, sort of big--
I think they call it the
white box or something.
And I can't tell you
what was in there.
But it was awesome.
It was awesome.
And it's really-- they're
such artists that work there.
It's incredible
how they figure out
how to make these
beautiful things
with these little
plastic bricks.
It's incredible.
So working on this book, my
research was really tough.
I mean, they had to--
they sent me 200
different LEGO sets.
And I built LEGOs.
It was really hard.
Actually, I got a couple
of interns to help me.
Because it takes a while.
I mean, I know some
of the parents know.
When you get those sets, it
takes a while, especially when
they're those big ones.
So we built everything.
And then we made--
then made the pops and
then made the artwork.
Here's a little sample of
what's inside "LEGO Pop-Up."
And I did the writing, the
pop-ups, and the art in this.
And there are cool pops
in this that transform.
This one transforms into
three different things.
And then there's
tons of many figures
and all kinds of cool things.
That's my assistant there,
works in Ninjago, too.
And it has this huge pop
in it that is super tall.
It's this big,
tall tower of pops.
Actually, we're going to
have a giveaway of some books
later on.
So think in your mind
about some cool LEGO facts.
Just think in your
head, and we'll
get back to that later on.
So enough already-- see, notes.
Tell them-- OK, so this
is how I do what I do.
When I work in my office down
in the West Village, all I do
is I stick paper in a machine
and pop-up books come out.
That's how I do it.
All right, I'm ready.
I'll see you later.
No, actually, that's
not what I do.
Don't you love my angry
face in that picture, too?
It's like rrr.
That's not how it's done.
It's actually a
really long process.
Making a pop-up book sometimes
takes from four to six months
to make a whole book from
the beginning to the end.
And then most of
that work has to be
done about eight months before
it's actually on the shelves.
Because after I
make one book, there
has to be a whole
group of people that
help me make thousands more.
So here's how it's done.
First, of course, I have
to get ideas for things.
I have to get inspiration.
I look all around me.
I look at the world everywhere
and try to take inspiration
from anything I can see.
You're lucky that you
guys are in New York.
There's so much here.
And I think most of the
pictures that are here,
I took in New York.
There's so much,
there's so much to see.
But I think that you
can be anywhere and be
inspired by things.
So I take inspiration
from everywhere.
And sometimes, you can see the
way that something is built.
And that might inspire you
to make something really cool
in a pop-up book.
So the tools I use
making pop-ups--
of course, after I've
written the story--
paper.
Yeah, I use a lot of cardstock.
I usually work in
white cardstock.
This is it right here.
You can get it.
It's a little heavier
than regular paper.
You can get it at office
stores and everything.
And the reason why
I use it in white
is, first, I want to figure
out what the structure is.
And then I worry
about coloring it
or drawing on it or whatever.
So usually in the beginning,
I just work in white paper.
I, of course, use tape.
I use different kinds of tape.
I use lots of scissors, glue, of
course, glue, an X-Acto knife.
The X-Acto knife I use to
make really intricate cuts.
And I need lots of Band-Aids,
because I don't just
make cuts on the paper.
Yes, I like Hello Kitty.
OK.
So in the beginning,
this is kind
of a rough pop-up looks like.
I may have an idea for what is
going to happen on that pop-up
page--
just words.
I will never draw a picture
of what I'm going to make.
I usually-- I just have a
word of what might happen.
So I just thought
to myself, I wanted
to have a pop-up that the
dinosaur bit the reader.
I thought that
would be really fun.
Because if you were going
to experience a T-rex, that
would be the coolest
way to-- well, I mean,
you wouldn't really
want to be eaten.
But it would be cool if
they kind of came at you.
So this is the first version.
And I'll take it
apart very carefully,
trace the pieces in the computer
using Adobe Illustrator.
And I'll make what
are called dyelines.
And these dye lines
are going to be
used later on for
when they manufacture
this thousands of times over.
So I will remake the pop-up
sometimes up to 10 times
or even 20 times to make sure
that it works just right.
And you can see there's even
notes on that and everything.
And that's what it
looks like in the final.
Now one of the
things that-- and I
also make the artwork as well.
And I'll show you
how I do that also.
I do a style of artwork
called cut paper collage.
So I'm cutting out
paper to make the pops.
I thought it would be
cool to also cut up paper
to make the art work as well.
Oh, in the beginning, this
is what a pop-up looks like.
This is just to get
the movement right.
Now I actually went and studied
a horse and how it moved.
And this was going to be
a book-- this book never
actually came out.
Oh, well.
Anyway-- wah, wah,
too bad for you.
It wasn't that exciting.
I swear.
I swear it's not.
So this is an early prototype
that actually sketches on it.
This is something that's
called a white dummy.
And it goes to my editor.
Now the editor works
at a publisher.
And she kind of
corrects all my work.
She kind of-- imagine,
it's like your teacher.
And she actually goes
through and marks
things that are written wrong.
Or she may even mark
some of the pops
and say, I don't think that this
is a good thing that you should
do, You should do
something else.
So she'll-- and just like a
teacher, she marks it in red.
So it's great when
you get that back.
But usually, I don't get--
I do OK with my editors.
And usually, they're on
the same page, so to speak.
Uh-huh.
I didn't mean to do that.
I'm sorry.
That's me when we're
making pop-ups.
And this is just-- show you
some of the details that
go into making it.
This is an early version
of the Darth Vader pop.
This was a really
tough pop-up to make,
because there's two portions
of Darth Vader's helmet.
Well, there's actually--
there's three.
There's-- I don't
want to get into it.
I'm not going to get into it.
But anyways, what happens
with this is actually I
wanted the reader to
be able to see Anakin
for a couple of seconds before
the mask closed up over him
when the pop-up opened.
So you can actually--
if you look
as it's opening, it's
really important,
the time-- you can
see him for a second.
And then it closes
up over his face.
Because everyone
makes-- everyone notices
those little things.
So this took me a
long time to be able--
and I had to actually engineer
the front part of his face
separately than the back
and then put them together.
So it took a lot of time
and a lot of prototypes
to get it to even
look like this.
So you see, I kind of
sculpted it in white first.
And then there's
sketches around it.
And then, and then, and then--
oh, that's the wrong thing.
And then that's the
final color version.
When I was doing this book, I
actually-- which was awesome--
I got-- I do get
some perks when I
work with some of these
different companies and things.
I got to go to the
Star Wars archives.
So this was the Lucas Film
Archives in Marin County.
This was actually
at Skywalker Ranch.
They don't even let
people go here anymore.
So I got in there
at the right time.
And they had all the
masks from the old movies.
Those are actual
stunt lightsabers.
That's my editor and
I. We were getting
ready to fight about something.
And those are stunt
lightsabers from him.
And the matte
painting in the back
is actually used from the
"Empire Strikes Back."
So I am like--
I couldn't stop smiling after.
This was so much fun to go see.
And did I need to go?
I remember when my
editor said, oh, you
think you're going to need
to go to the Lucas Archives
to look at things?
Now, I-- no.
Let me-- at the time, I owned
hundreds of Star Wars books.
I had every movie.
I have tons.
I knew everything about it.
Of course, I said, yes, I
think I should probably go.
So I was able to go.
It was an awesome experience.
And I've had a lot
of nice experiences
like that, like
the big fan in me
gets to go do these cool things.
This is me working in my
studio-- not this fast.
This is, yeah-- this is
me working in the studio
probably over a few hours.
And I'm designing a pop-up.
And as you can see,
it's just by hand.
There's no computer program.
The computer program
comes in when I actually
take the pop apart and trace it.
Now after I've made all those
dyelines, all those lines that
are tracings of pieces, I
may go in and make artwork.
Sometimes it's in the computer.
Sometimes it's by hand.
And I put the artwork
and those dyelines
together, rebuild
the pop-up again
and again to make sure it works.
And that is how
a pop-up is made.
This was for the
Transformers pop-up book.
Like I said, I
love Transformers.
That was just a quick pop-up
how to make for that book.
That was an incredible
book to do as well.
I have a lot of dream
projects that come true.
People always ask me, you must
not have any more dreams left.
I'm like, let me tell you.
I got lots.
There's always something
else that I want to do.
I have a lot of dreams.
This is just a prototype
of what the book was
like before it was in color.
And sometimes I do the artwork.
And sometimes other
people do the artwork.
Like I said, I worked
with Maurice Sendak once.
And for this book,
I actually worked
with a great Transformer artist
named Emiliano Santalucia.
He lives in Italy.
I actually never got to
see him the whole time.
We worked over-- we just
sent things back and forth
to each other over the internet.
And I would draw the
initial sort of sketch
and what he should draw
and made all kinds of notes
about what, where, and
what it should look like.
And then he would make the art.
And then I would put that
with those dyeline pieces.
So you can see sometimes
for one pop-up,
there might be 30 different
pieces that work in tandem,
all these different levers and
different mechanics working
together.
Or there may be other times
when I make the artwork myself.
Now I think about
making a pop-up.
OK, so there's three different
stages in making pop-ups.
You have to have the
writing done and the--
whatever research and writing.
That's like a cake.
When you're making a
cake, that's the recipe.
You got to have that.
The next step is
the actual cake.
You're actually going
to bake something.
So the next step is
actually making the cake.
And then the artwork
is the frosting to me.
I love frosting, so
making color artwork.
Now I said I make a style
called cut paper collage.
And I actually, by hand, make
all these different types
of art.
Sometimes it's digital.
But usually, it's by hand.
I take all these
papers that I've
made in my studio, all
these different textures.
I have a huge rack of
different new papers
that we're constantly using.
And I will show you a
little bit how it's done.
First, I'll draw a
picture, just very quickly.
I usually tighten up a sketch.
And then I'll use
that sketch as my map.
And I'll cut out sections
of different colored
paper with my X-Acto knife.
I'll lay it in the place using
my sketch sort of as a guide.
And I printed on a
clear piece of plastic.
Then I'll glue in the different
pieces of colored paper.
And the glue I use is very
similar to Elmer's glue,
white glue.
And then that's what the
final thing will look like.
And it's a very small
piece of artwork.
But it may have 20 different
little pieces of paper
all glued together to make one.
Sometimes some of
my larger pieces
may have hundreds of pieces
of paper glued together.
When I make the artwork
for the pop-up pieces,
it's a little different.
I have to make the artwork
like all splatted out.
And it almost looks like--
it's like pop-up roadkill.
They're all over the side.
There's pieces here and there.
And after so many
years, I figured out
where each piece
needs to be and what
needs to be on which piece.
So sometimes the head
isn't necessarily connected
to the body.
So I figured it out
after a long time.
But the one thing I don't
really say to you guys--
didn't say that earlier--
was there a lot of
mistakes along the way.
I don't just start out and
have the perfect idea at first.
And it all looks great.
For every wow
pop-up that you see,
there's a lot of not so
wows that get thrown out.
And that's the way
I figure things out.
I sort of--
I will make something and
see if it's something I like.
If it's not, then I try
something different.
And that's-- hopefully you
guys can get from this,
it doesn't come out perfect.
And it's OK, because
we're supposed
to learn from our mistakes.
I've made so many of them,
you wouldn't even know.
And it's OK to do that, because
that's how we get better.
So I've made up one pop-up.
I've made all the art.
I've made all the pops.
And I've made all the words.
Now what do I do?
So I send all that.
And I send one
pop-up book that I
made by hand to a manufacturer.
And they're actually-- pop-up
books are hand-manufactured.
Once I make one pop-up
book, the next step
is sending all that
information to a printer
and a hand-assembly
manufacturer.
And so that's all set.
Usually, the work
is done overseas.
And I've worked with a lot of
these manufacturers for years,
so they understand how
to put together pop-ups.
In fact, they're more of
experts in assembling pop-ups
than I could ever be.
And they tell me things.
This doesn't work.
This will work.
Here's some ideas about things.
So what they'll do
is they'll break down
the book into different groups.
And one group will make
just one page of a book.
And so each person,
they'll remake--
each person will make
one section of it.
So for example, this
Atat here, one person
will assemble this leg and
hand it off to the next person.
And there will be a large group
that just works on this page.
And they'll make thousands.
Sometimes they can make up
to, like, 15,000 a week.
They're really hand-- they're
really incredibly skilled hand
laborers.
And they oftentimes
come up with ideas
that are way better than
what I come up with.
So I work the entire time
during that production,
which is usually, like I
said, about eight months
before a book hits the shelves.
So they'll send me prototypes.
And then once they actually
start building the books,
they can make up
to 15,000 a week.
They'll package them up.
After they've made each spread,
they'll glue them together.
Then they'll glue a cover on it.
They'll clamp
them, let them dry.
And then they will get
shipped off in boxes
all over the world.
So it kind of goes from my
hands creating the original book
to the manufacturer's hands to
your hands in the bookstores.
So it's really too cool.
But there are a lot of
products that we don't realize
are made by hand when they are.
There isn't some
giant machine that
will do all this work for us.
There are some really
intricate things that we have
and that we buy.
And there are hands
that go into it.
So now I'm going to show you--
now that I've talked about
myself enough--
we're going to make
a pop right here.
And I'm going to
show you some basics.
But I'm going to need an
idea for what I should make.
Now last time, someone came
up with a really crazy idea.
And I did it, of course.
But it was something.
It was pretty funny.
So anyone got an idea?
You want to raise your hand.
And I'll pick-- let's see.
Let's see.
Thing OK, you.
Yes.
Plants?
OK.
That works.
Well, I like this green.
So I'm going to use that for
the actual plants, I think.
So what I'm going to start
with is just this cardstock.
I'm going to fold it in half.
Oh, I've already got an idea.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, yeah.
So-- OK, we're
going to start off.
This is-- we took
a piece of paper.
And we're going to fold it
in half, just like that.
All right.
And just for the sake of
being able to see it on video,
I'm going to make a
line down the center
so it's a little easier to see.
So you see that center line?
We're going to-- when we
make some of our pieces,
we're going to align it.
We're going to line up
the folds on things.
Because that's a lot of
what pop-up people do.
They line up different folds
to make sure things work right.
So one of the things
I'm going to make
is something called a V-fold.
And a V-fold is actually--
well, it's shaped like a V.
And most of the pop-up
in most of my books
use some form of V-fold.
That's not a good one.
OK, see this big dinosaur?
See this piece
underneath his body here?
That-- and it's sort
of triangular and V--
so that's a V.
And you can see that it moves.
It actually is forcing all
these pieces to move up.
So a V-fold moves.
And so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to make two V-folds.
And I'm going make
two V-folds that are--
they're both right angles.
Right angles are 90
degree angles, right?
Correct-- I mean, correct.
So let's see here.
I'm going to take a piece of--
I'm going take a
different piece.
I'm going to take gray so
that you can see these pieces.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to make-- first,
I'm going to make a square,
a small square, out of paper.
And then I'm going to make two
triangles from that square.
And you say, Matthew,
how can that be done?
I just don't know.
Well, OK, so I just
folded a rectangle, right?
And now-- correct, I mean.
Because if I say right
angle, it's very confusing.
So then I'm going to fold
this triangle down like this.
And I'll be able to see if I
cut it along the edge like that
and like that.
Then we have a square.
Because this side, this side,
this side, and this side--
it's pretty close.
It's pretty close.
And we need two
triangles that are--
oh, if I cut this
down the middle,
I get two triangles
that are equal, right?
We're learning
geometry too, today.
Good thing you're not in school.
You know, it's funny.
People say all the time, you
must have been really good
at geometry.
And I don't remember.
I don't think I--
I think I-- no, I wasn't.
I was not a great math student.
I did OK.
But calculus-- oh,
man, did that kill me.
So there-- we have
two triangles.
And what we're going to
do is fold them in half.
And we're going to
make two V-folds.
There's one.
And the fold where the V is
is going to be down here.
And here's the second one.
And we're going to tape
these onto our base.
And you know what
I'm going to do?
I'm going to make a line on
that fold, just so we know--
so you can see it better.
Because last time, we,
couldn't see it as well.
My shirt is really
open, isn't it?
Yikes!
I'm giving you a lot
of cleavage today.
All right, so here
are our V-folds.
And we're going to
have them actually--
when we glue them
onto to the page,
we're going to have them point--
the points touching.
So we're going to make sure that
that center line on the top V
is lined up with the
main base, page one.
And we're going to do the same
on the bottom, just like that.
It kind of looks like an
hourglass a little bit, right?
And I'm going to use some
white tape, if I have it.
Yes.
So I use this tape that's
very similar to masking tape
in my studio.
It's artist tape.
And we're going to tape along
the V. Because it's a V-fold.
And there is one lined
up just like that.
And I always make
sure that I push--
I make sure that that tape
is really secure on there.
So now we can see when it moves.
See, there's one V.
Now we want another V.
But it's going to
go the other way.
Actually, I'm going to move
it more towards the middle.
That's the other thing.
You can't be--
don't be afraid when
you're making these pop-ups.
Don't be afraid to
pick up the pieces
and move them around if you
don't like the way they are.
You can always change.
You can always remake
and fix your mistakes.
Just by the way, I also--
I'm supposed to remember
all my social media stuff.
Because I'm not real good at it.
So I have a YouTube page where
you can make your own pops.
If you look up
Matthew Reinhart, it's
called "Let's Make It Pop."
And I have different crafts.
I'm trying to do
them every week.
So if I miss a week,
please don't get mad at me.
But there's always
different things.
In fact, tomorrow is
national superhero day.
So wear your cape.
OK?
Anyways, tomorrow is
national superhero day.
And there's a pop-up superhero
card that we made for--
and I think it went up today.
So you can make your
own superhero card.
So there's one V. And I'm going
to attach the second V. I know,
a plant.
I'm going a plant.
I'm going to attach this.
And then what we're
going to do, once we
have these two Vs working
in opposite directions,
then we're going
to make something--
it's a mechanism.
Here, I'm going to show you.
There are the two, all right?
And look, they're going
in different directions.
One's going up.
One's going down.
What's cool about this is one
side, like this lower triangle
here, if we attach
something to the edge
here, on the opposite side on
the top on that same edge--
so on the opposite side.
So let's see.
I'm looking at myself on
the-- there and there.
So if we make a
bridge going across--
if we make a bridge going--
I was trying to watch
myself in this thing.
And I was like, wait,
what's going on?
If we make a bridge going
across, we'll actually--
we'll be able to
connect the two.
And we'll make a pop-up that
kind of expands and twists.
So it's really cool.
So the next thing
we're going to do
is we're going to kind of make
a little bit thinner, longer,
sort of bridge piece.
And I'm going to mark
with another color
the edges that we're
going to connect.
Can you guys see
that there, there?
And then I'm going to see--
did I make?
I didn't make that long enough.
If you saw my studio,
it is a wreck.
I mean, there's
paper everywhere.
Sometimes I'll come out of
my office after a long day,
and I'll just have
paper all over.
I won't even realize it.
And people like--
you'll get home.
And it's like, there's
something on your shirt.
And it's like this huge piece
of paper or half of a pop-up.
Nobody told me this
on the way out?
OK so, it's going to go across.
The only thing that
is not going to work
is we need to snip off this
little bit and this little bit.
So I'm just going to use my
marker and roughly get a line.
So there, you can see where
I'm supposed to cut it.
I'm going to snip and
snip, use my tape.
And we're going to attach this.
And what's cool with
this is we're going
to do a part where it kind of--
OK, so now, we are going to
attach it from under here.
We'll have the tape go up.
Like I said, this pop-up
is called a twister
because it twists.
Oh, that's cool.
The reminder-- Matthew,
please shut up soon.
All right, here we go.
All right, so now, it's attached
from here all the way across.
There's a bridge.
And when we close it, see
how it's sort of bowing?
We don't want that.
I mean, come on, man.
Just going to make
sure it's attached
right and that you have your
tape on there pretty hard.
All right, so we're
going to fold it.
And it's going to
sort of arc like that.
And what's going to happen
is you're going to fold it.
And it will-- you're
going to find the fold.
So you're going to kind
of press down on your pop
and smash it a little.
So now, I'm a very
sensitive artist, OK?
So when I open this, I need
positive reinforcement.
So I'm going to need
to say, like, ooh,
like be really surprised and
excited when you see it, OK.
Let me make sure.
OK.
All right.
[OOHING]
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Wow.
That's really exciting.
All right.
But this is the start of what--
we can start building
on top of this.
So let's see.
Hm.
What can we-- so we're going
to make a plant, right?
So first, we need some leaves.
And every surface
that's here, it
has potential to become
a part of the pop-up.
So I'm going to use
double-stick tape.
Now usually, I use glue.
But because I don't
have a lot of time--
there we go.
So there is a leaf
and another leaf.
So are you guys
having fun today?
You learning a lot about what
your moms and dads and everyone
else, all your parents, do?
Is it boring?
No?
OK, good.
I didn't think it
would be boring here.
Every time I pass by here--
so I live in New York.
I live actually in Chelsea,
a few blocks from here.
Every time I pass by
the Google building,
I always think to myself,
god, I want a job there.
Because everyone
looks like they're
so having fun and smart.
And here I am on my bike.
And I'm covered with paper
and sad and pathetic.
So there's the
start of my plant.
Maybe I'll put some leaves here.
But whatever you're doing
here, it seems exciting.
And so it's cool to be able to
get an idea of what people do.
OK, I'm starting
to get more here.
It's still-- and I'm just
adding pieces of paper.
Let's see.
And it doesn't look as
pretty in the beginning.
Sometimes, it's just
getting those shapes right.
And here-- see.
OK.
Well, they're getting
a little better.
I mean, they wouldn't be hiring
me for the Google Doodles
anytime soon on that one.
Let's see, we also maybe--
most plants kind of need
a little pot to go in.
So we'll cut a little
shape down here.
Oh, by the way--
should we do that now
while I finish this up?
We are going to give away--
how many books do we have?
Four?
We have four books to give away.
Now I'm sorry we
don't have a lot more.
But that's all we had
to give away for today.
You can find my books
anywhere, like any bookstore.
You can find it online at
Amazon, all those places,
even places like Toys R
Us and things like that.
So they're everywhere.
Like I said, I have
a YouTube channel.
You can find me on Facebook.
There's a pop-up book
by Matthew Reinhart.
So I'm all over the place.
And we're going to do a quick--
we're going to have people--
if you have a LEGO fact, I
want you to raise your hand.
And Lauren will pick--
now you have to tell
us what your fact is.
And then you get the book.
So Lauren, why don't
you start going ahead?
And I'll finish up my pop-up
while you started doing that.
And you have to speak
up so we can hear you.
That's part of it.
You have to-- and
you can make it up.
All right, shh.
83-- that's right.
Give the man a book.
Congratulations.
And I will sign
your book at the end
after we're finished
if you like.
Oh, the fact was it's been
around-- how many years?
83 years.
What?
OK, go for it.
Oh, yeah, that sounds right.
That sounds good.
Awesome.
Congratulations.
That's right.
And it's actually
in my LEGO pop.
You get to see that, the
evolution of many figures.
How many-- now do you guys
have lots of LEGO mini figures?
It's kind of insane
how many there are now.
OK, I'm still working on this.
SPEAKER: LEGO headquarters
are in Denmark.
MATTHEW REINHART: Shh.
What?
SPEAKER: LEGO headquarters
are in Denmark.
MATTHEW REINHART: Really?
I mean, yes.
I thought you said
something about quarters.
I was like, what?
Headquarters-- yes, of
course, I was there, totally.
I'm sorry.
I'm out of it, you guys.
All right, so awesome--
congratulations
everybody who won the book.
And like I said, I
will definitely--
so wait, I'm not quite done.
So she said she wanted a plant.
But you know, plants aren't
always the most active things.
Of course, the first
thing she said--
of when she first said
it, I thought, well,
I'll make a plant.
But I'm going to make this
plant into a Venus flytrap.
Because let's see-- I've
lost some of my-- let's see.
If I put the neck up
here, oh, yeah, totally.
Totally.
I had a friend who was
in one of those musicals.
And he wasn't so good.
It was a community theater.
And I had to go see him sing it.
He was Seymour.
He wasn't so good at it.
So let's see if that works.
Is that going to work?
It's going.
Now like I said, sometimes we
don't get everything right.
So you got to keep trying.
Here we go.
And I lost a leaf in there.
It's hard to do it on the fly.
Let's see if that works.
There we go.
Now it sticks out.
I cheated a little bit.
But there we go.
Oh, we lost a leaf.
[APPLAUSE]
It's not bad.
I could use a little
bit more work.
If I had more time, I'd be
able to make some cooler.
But anyways, thank you so
much for having me today.
You guys were awesome.
And if you ever want to
make any pop-ups, go online.
And have a good day today.
Bye, you all.
[APPLAUSE]